Уряд Німеччини засудив заяву ватажків бойовиків щодо заснування нібито нової держави – Малоросії.
У коментарі DW речниця уряду ФРН назвала цей крок повністю неприйнятним.
Щоправда, німецькі політики з партії "Зелених" вважають - шансів дочекатися,
що Москва критикуватиме лідерів сепарастистів - майже нуль.
Зелені впевнені: режим на Донбасі повністю залежить від військової та фінансової підтримки Кремля.
Рішення про нові псевдодержави бойовики навряд ухвалили б самотужки, вважають у політсилі.
На думку експертів, саме поняття "Малоросія" -  більш притаманне саме російській ідеології.
Сумніваюся, що цей крок не був узгоджений з Кремлем,
і що пан Захарченко з власної ініціативи виступив перед державними інформагенствами Росії.
Малоросія – історичне поняття, я не впевнений, що воно потрібне сепаратистам.
Це радше спроба сприймати Україну не як суверенну державу, а як частину великої Російської імперії.
Заяви про Малоросію – абсурд, впевнений Майстер. Тому що все більше населення  України
консолідується навколо української ідентичності і навколо протистояння з РФ.
Ці заяви не мають нічого спільного з реальністю. Але крок Захарченка чітко показує,
що ані російське керівництво, ані сепаратисти жодним чином не зацікавлені у мінському процесі.
Натомість вони оголошують нові ініціативи.
Пропозиція створити Малоросію - це просто димова шашка без вибухового потенціалу.
Про оголошення нової держави, так званої Малоросії, спадкоємицею України
з центром у Донецьку бойовики заявили у вівторок. Тим часом у Берліні впевнені:
переговори - єдиний шлях вирішення конфлікту в Україні. Ідеться, зокрема, про виконання мінських угод.